we can review time and it's been a big
week obviously Super Bowl 54 caps the
NFL's 100th season it ended up being a
great Super Bowl thanks to the Chiefs
ability to mash the gas pedal in the
final half of the fourth quarter so big
cat there's been so many people and I've
seen some who suggested that the Chiefs
are already a dynasty you can't be a
dynasty if you've only won one Super
Bowl one Super Bowl win plus the promise
of more does not a dynasty make they
have to go back and do it and their head
coach Andy Reid this week at the parade
said we're having another parade next
year which is the closest that he could
come to saying he's guaranteeing another
Super Bowl win are we on the front end
of a Kansas City dynasty who give me the
name of the person who said this is
already a dynasty I've seen some stuff
on social Malatesta it's already I saw
it somewhere because I saw somebody call
them out was it may have been you that
called them out this is going to be the
big test though because you know Patrick
mahomes
and a credit to him he's such a special
player that when he wins a Super Bowl
it's not like oh my god Patrick mahomes
he's such a special player it's
immediately how many Super Bowls will
Patrick from homes win you know will he
dominate the next 15 years so you just
said in the intro to this show to this
hour that if he doesn't win four Super
Bowls his career will be deemed a
failure is that was that quota that's
not what I said that's not how I said it
my point is my point is how many does he
have to win for us in hindsight to say
he lived up to his potential because
we're thinking now he's gonna get but
he's good if he's gonna be the greatest
ever doesn't he have to at least get
within shouting distance of Tom Brady
and total championships it's so hard to
win Super Bowls though I think if you
win three Super Bowls you're in that
rarefied air I mean how many guys have
three Super Bowls is it just Joe Montana
Tom Brady and Terry Bradshaw it's in a
Quinn yes it's four so he would be the
fifth quarterback to do that I think
that would be a rarefied air that would
put them in that conversation of you
know but that's who he is
that's who he is that's my point it's
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
helium-3 three would make that I think
the category I think there's a lot of
guys we're very very good who won two
Super Bowls and then once you get to the
third then you're in that group with
Terry Bradshaw Tom Brady Joe Montana and
Troy Aikman if you can get into that
group of guys who have only won three
Super Bowls the starting quarterbacks
then the conversation changes I think he
already could have - I mean a coin flip
last year goes differently in the AFC
Champions you're tired yeah give him a
second there's nothing and you know what
I'll give him I'll give him a third
because when the Chiefs offense was
struggling in 2017 and those players and
coaches knew what Patrick mahomes could
do and they didn't bench Alex Smith they
could have won in 2017 they could
already be a dynasty he could already
have three three years into his career
how about that my point is this the
guy's incredible and to see how he
overcame the adversity week in and week
out to come back from down 24 to come
back from down 10 to come back from down
10 with less than a quarter left in
Super Bowl 50 for it creates the
impression he can do anything in a point
Sims made once you get that early Super
Bowl in your career the pressure to get
one is off and you have a greater
freedom big cat you know I think that
one of the things packed mahomes learned
in Super Bowl 54 I think he was a little
tight and he was a little stiff and he
was a little too aware of the moment
when they were down late and he said
screw it I'm just gonna go play my game
and it worked
I think his attitude for the rest of his
career is gonna be screw it I'm just
gonna go play my game and we've seen
time and again that's more than good
enough to deliver Super Bowl
championships
so you it's interesting to me how we
always do this in sports as well because
if you went back in time and you asked
how many Super Bowls are there and
Rogers win what would you say what would
you set up for he beat the Steelers in
the Super Bowl I would have said he's
got two more yeah and he probably
doesn't have a single one more you know
like that's that's how hard it is to win
Super Bowls that's how hard it is drew
back to their briefs good top of the
mountain yeah Brett Favre hey here's the
best comparison here's the best
comparison Russell Wilson he got his
Super Bowl year - and he's still waiting
and waiting and waiting to get number
two seeing
he's great young quarterbacks he's gonna
have to compete with now that he's 31
going on 32 later this year and and I
say it's not gonna be easy from a homes
but I think the greatness is there and I
think it's fair to expect that he's
gonna have a fistful of rings he's gonna
be like Belichick with the ultimate flex
he's gonna put up that double think the
ultimate flex that was not the ultimate
flex I hate the internet sometimes the
ultimate flex would have been if he wore
all his rings I don't know why you only
wore three but everyone's like look at
the old can't wear more than that there
took that's not the ultimate flex he
literally could wear six rings he wear
eight if he wanted to that would be the
ultimate flex back to Patrick more homes
real quick Mike he should get a necklace
that you know what he should have a
necklace it has all you get a keychain
like a janitor with a bunch of keys it's
a good point will Patrick mahomes be the
type of guy to take the absolute max
amount of dollars or is he going to be
the type of guy who similar to Tom Brady
maybe taste a little less to try to help
out the rest of the roster because
that's where this equation changes when
Patrick mahomes when you get year five
six seven and he's getting paid a ton of
money yeah there's not enough money to
go around you're really really good
every year so you're always at the
bottom of the draft the margin for error
becomes so much thinner and that's when
true greatness comes out and we'll
Patrick mahomes be able to do that I
mean you never talk about another man's
money but do you think Patrick Moore
Holmes is that type of guy who's maybe
says look I want to get paid a lot I
want to get paid you know a lot a lot
but I don't need the absolute max
because I want to make sure this team is
competitive and you have guys that I can
throw to because we've seen it in the
NFL a quarterbacks you know career span
life span so to speak is a lot longer
than every other guy on that team so if
we flash forward 15 years from now
Patrick mahomes will still be playing
quarterback and that entire roster will
be different and that overturn will be
the key you know decision on how many
Super Bowls
Patrick mahomes can end up winning he
made the comment earlier this week about
making sure the
there's a team around him so I think
he'll be sensitive to it now Peyton
Manning's attitude always was it's my
job to play quarterback and get paid as
much as I can it's your job to manage a
salary cap and the rookie weight scale
gives the Chiefs away every year to
replenish the roster with cheap talent
and they can continuously draft guys who
are good and they've shown with Brett
veatch's of GM Andy Reid as the head
coach they know how to find those good
young cheap guys who will always be
churning through the roster and then
elsewhere if they want to get paid a lot
of money I think what Patrick mahomes
needs to do and there have been players
who have tried to do this Darrell Rivas
tried to do it 10 years ago it didn't
work
Kirk Cousins tried to do it in
Washington I think he may have tried to
do it in free agency it didn't work
the management council is opposed to the
concept although I don't know why they
are Patrick mahomes compensation should
be tied to a set percentage of the
salary cap 15 16 17 18 percent no more
than 20 that should be his pay every
year that ensures he's fairly
compensated that ensures that as the pie
grows he continues to get his fair piece
of it and it leaves 80 to 85 percent of
the total cap available for them to fill
out the rest of the roster that's what
he should want and the Chiefs should
give it to him you are a GM look at that
your GM no no because nobody's ever done
it no no one's ever done it they don't
want to do it the Management Council
doesn't want the team's to do it so the
teams don't do it I think the first team
that will ever do it would be the
Panthers and David Tepper because he's
already shown he's willing to stick his
finger in the eye of the establishment
and overpay a head coach on the way in
and mat rule the management council does
not want these teams to do it it's
collusion for the management council to
send out this message and for teams to
not do it it's available and I think
mahomes is the guy who deserves it we'll
see how hard he and his age at least
Steinberg push for it but I think they
should yeah no they absolutely should
but this is gonna be I really do think
that like what patch screw Holmes does
with this contract will tell the story
for the next five years on what the
Chiefs are gonna be and how many Super
Bowls the ends up winning it's also I
mean it's
unfair that the Patrick mahomes you know
in discussing how great he's gonna be
has to follow Tom Brady because now the
bar is completely changed on on success
you're talking about him winning three
Super Bowls and having it be not living
up to the hype like that's crazy
but it's not so so crazy anymore because
Tom Brady has six we had all those years
where you could make a reasonable
argument for five six seven different
quarterbacks is the greatest of all time
Montana and the Rings Terry Bradshaw in
his rings and the perfect record in the
Super Bowl but then Elway in the stats
and Marino even though he never won a
Super Bowl and then comes Brady once he
passed for once he got the five and
definitely once he got to six it was
clear he's the greatest ever and it that
it's gonna be interesting to see whether
mahomes can leapfrog Brady without
leapfrogging him in total championships
it's gonna be hard to do it's gonna be
very hard to do I mean what's he got 15
more years you're talking about five
more in 15 years that's one every three
years that is not an easy thing to do
and a lot of planets have to line up the
right way but big cat if we've ever seen
a quarterback who can do it
it's the ultimate magician and Patrick
mahomes the guy who can erase a twenty
four point deficit like that a guy who
can come back from ten nothing with
seven minutes left in a Super Bowl and
win the game the guy's incredible we've
never seen anything like him before
that's what makes me think at the end of
the day and look I don't want to wish
the next 15 years of my life away for
crying out loud
but I'm curious to see and I'm
fascinated to see what he does with this
level of skill that we have never seen
before
geez Mike you really do want to just end
up being what they eat how old do you be
when Pat from home 15 years down in LA
you be 80 I'll be having to pay for you
in a nursing home we'll be sitting there
I'll come watch the suit no that stuff
is funny you sauce yeah no I will I will
that's the type of guy I am when
everyone when the world has forgotten
Mike Florio I'll be there we'll sit
there we'll watch the Super Bowl every
year I won't I'm not gonna say we'll
watch it live I'll probably play a trick
on you and we'll probably watch it the
next day tape delay and I'll tell you
it's live but I'm gonna be there
we're gonna watch Patrick we're home
lift Lombardi number six in twenty years
time it's good to know that you were
raised on the foundation of always
respecting your outers rightly
refreshing to know that somewhere in
Wisconsin or wherever the hell it is
that you grew up that was instilled in
you at a young age I got you man
I got you I Mike Florio I got you don't
worry about it right I love you when we
return well thank you very much I love
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports